Logan Burdick, Screenwriter: The magic of
being a screenwriter or any of these crafts
is to figure out the pattern
and then once you understand it
then figure out how to bury it so that
no one's paying any attention to it.
Film Courage: Logan, what can you tell
someone that's never written a screenplay
but loves film and television
about the craft of screenwriting?
Logan: I think obviously it goes without
saying that you have to read scripts.
I don't know how you would approach it otherwise.
I feel actually reading them and then trying to
figure out through whatever means are available to
you whether that's reading books or just trying to
take things apart yourself how do you reverse
engineer to figure out why this works right
and the hard thing with that is that there's a
lot of things scripts are doing simultaneously
right you have to figure out why it works
from a pacing perspective and a plot for
perspective and a character perspective and in
theme and emotional arcs and all those things
but I think that the best way to do that is to
read scripts and then try to reverse engineer them
and again there's a lot of there's a lot of great
material where people have done that Robert Mckee
and I forget who wrote save the cat I know I have
not read Save The Cat but I definitely read story
when I was younger the only other
thing that I would say about it is
don't think that any one way is the
only wayI think it's important to to
immerse yourself in a bunch of
different people's perspectives
and then I feel by doing that you'll actually
start to understand why it's working I think that
emulating is important is an important part of
learning right even literally children learn
at the very beginning by just copying right
they're just emulating what someone else is
doing they don't understand why that's important
but I think to really transcend that you need
to figure out why it's working and you have to
understand it on a much more intrinsic level of
againI always hate to be too mathematical about
it but so much of it is why why this line here why
this beat here what was planted when and why does
it pay off here and okay sure that was all done
just from a thematic place but are there
different ways that you can infuse that
to from a character perspective or again whatever
that means because all these different attributes
are all again happening in parallel but I
do feel that's what's really important is
again immersing yourself both in the raw
material scripts and movies oh and all literally
sorry I'm just having thoughts I'm doing this
sometimes if there's a type of movie that
I'm interested in figuring out why it works in
certain ways I'll literally I will both read
the script and then I will watch the actual movie
and then I will time out the movie and I will see
when I will see what in the script how many
how many scenes and where they were and what
was happening in them and then all I'll put that
against the actual finished movie and then I'll
say oh okay because sometimes when someone writes
the script that isn't what ended up working the
best in the movie right and sometimes you need to
look at the final holistic project to go oh okay
this is the they made these decisions that even
the writer themselves were not thinking about but
if you watch enough material and you read enough
material you'll find you should find the patternsI
think that the literally the again the magicians
the magic of being a screenwriter or any of these
crafts is to figure out the pattern and then once
you understand it then figure out how to bury it
so that no one's paying any attention to it right
that's not fun for anyone people want people want
the experience to be new and fresh and interesting
but even the stuff that is new and fresh and
interesting if you really start digging in you'll
find it's the similar building blocks that's what
I would say so when you see something that you you
resonate with you want to really dissect why did
this work for me and then you want to look at the
script and then time it with the actual maybe even
have the sound down at times just to see some
of the pacing and things that because to you
that's a magical product how did it become
magical that yeah it's just really to me it really
is reverse engineering it's if I walk into a
building it's it's amazing that the ac is running
if without seeing the blueprints I'm not going to
understand I'm not going to understand why the ac
is running or how it's running or why they why did
they place it here because I'm just lost I'm just
lost in the experience of it right but all those
there's thousands of decisions that are made as to
why and however you start being able to figure
out on your own how to get to those answers
I think is really important and again to me the
best way to do that is to just look at a lot of
blueprints and to really dive as deep into
them as you can and then again looking at what
people who are experts say and understanding why
they said the things they said and then also take
it with a grain of salt because there's they're
also not the end-all be-all it's important to
it's important to be able to listen to everyone
and take it all in and realize why they're saying
it and then figure out how you want to implement
that right it's that balance you have to respect
the experts at it but you also have to then
figure out how to take what they're doing and
try to put your own unique spin on it what's
the wrong way to start screenwriting the wrong
way to start screenwriting the only thing that
I will I don't know I don't know the wrong way
to start screenwriting I if I'm I do feel that
there's no real wrong way to be creative right
and that's different for everyone and it should be
I think that to me the only thing I would advise
is to be to be conscientious of your time because
you can play around with something forever
and maybe that's all you want to do but I think
that I think that the more tools you can have to
try to stay on track while still giving
yourself freedom to play I think that's the best
the best meeting of the worlds and I will also say
that I do think that it is also important to be
aware that it is a business and that and to have
fun and to be creative and play but also be aware
for yourself that if you're writing something
that's not that's not there's not a market for
maybe there will be but there's also
a good possibility that there won't be
and you have to make peace with that and
if that's and if that's cool with you
then that's fine again that's that's you and your
time but if you really if you're really trying to
figure out how to transition into a into a career
that's something thatI would say I wouldn't
I would not pay attention to
that I think a lot of times
people don't pay attention to things that they
find discouraging or uncomfortable or negative
you need my you need my suggestion would
be to really look at it in in the eyes
acknowledge it you it's the difference between
what some what something is and what you want
it to be right you can even look something in the
eyes of what it is and go I don't love what that
is i'd to change it i'd to it for it to evolve and
become better that's all fine but I would still
I would still start by going but this is
what I'm up against this is what people
are looking for this is what's expected
this is all what the landscape really is
what that information is even if you don't it
even if it's scary or it makes you feel bad
you're not going to figure out ways to
approach it and work with it or around it
or however you want to do it if you don't know
what it is from my from my perspective anyway
when you were working on it takes three were there
times in your head where you're I'm not sure if
someone's going to it how well it will be received
and then how much time am I going to spend with it
were you questioning yourself to
at that time because you were still
it was if you said you were working on
it in a few months the in that situation
to me to me the next step always is is once I've
come to terms with that I'm going to undertake
a project whatever that is then I then I
fall in love with it there's no point in
unless something's really not working
right and that's a different story
but otherwise I'm I wish I knew there's a very
famous quote about this but it's basically some
version of you do everything you can to prepare
and then you just go and that's I at least again
for me I find that that's what's always been how I
make decisions is I do I do the most ground work I
can to feel as confident and good about something
as I can and then I don't worry about that anymore
and then I just focus on being creative
and doing the best job that I can
because otherwise you're you're just second
guessing yourself for no point you've made
you've made an informed decision stick with
your informed decision and then if it fails
or or it doesn't get what you were expecting out
of it to me I to me outside of again that first
thesis film everything I've done that's been
that hasn't gotten me what I expected or would
have liked to have gotten out of it I don't
have any regrets about because I believed in it
and I still believe in it I think that sometimes
that doesn't matter there's so many other factors
at play you try to make the best informed decision
of you that you can about why you're undertaking
a project and then you basically you just give it
your all and you don't worry about whether or not
it will be successful or it'll do what you
were expecting it to do because you should feel
confident in it even if external forces don't
line up in a certain way that gets the result
that you want because sometimes that happens and
that's not your fault and it has nothing to do
with the project and so that's why I
think that I try to approach it that way.
What do you like about this video?